When you see thousands of people that
are innocent that got killed by drones,
a million innocence killed in Iraq.
If that's not a crime against humanity,
what is a crime against you?
Morning.
Okay.
A lot of shit comes up that
people would want to vote on,
like the bailouts,
the war.
I'll think things of this nature.
There's a lot of things
that people would like.
It's going to affect us.
We would like to vote on this,
but you don't get devoted.
You get to vote on a representative.
These people are going to represent you.
Once they get into office and thinking
about some of the laws that are in place
to protect corporations,
think about some of the laws that are in
place that fuck people over every day.
They wouldn't be there.
People were voting for them.
We all have this,
this desire to have someone lead us.
this feeling where we need
someone who's smarter and wiser,
who represents us.
You know,
and when you really fucking dumb,
the problem is really dumb.
People,
they get a say in everything too,
and they're,
they're subject to a lot of tricks there
subjects to that they're subject to
nationalism.
They're subject to these
kind of ridiculous Rah Rah
Rah America speeches that
don't say Jack Shit.
They say nothing.
It's all just this cheerleading fucking
event and they they're subject to,
they can't help it.
They're dumb.
They don't know they're
being bullshitted dude.
They grew up around dumb people.
They go to work with don people.
There's no one in their family that's
interesting or ask any questions at all
and they just get stuck
right into it.
Man,
it's a,
society is so greedy.
We're willing to go to war.
We're willing to go places in [inaudible],
these big metal machines that kill people
and fuck people up just so we can make
more money.
And the way our society is set up,
I mean,
I've heard it argued and argued
successfully that our society runs on war.
You know,
it runs on the domination of the other
parts of the world and literally that's
the only way you can control
a gigantic chunk of the glove.
You have to keep everybody down.
You know,
and that's what our society is based on.
We can't be fighting over each other
because you know this guys are like a
million people die in Iraq.
And he goes,
Hey,
well I'm just doesn't happen over here.
But it is that is over here.
It's just over here,
over there.
It's the same thing.
And some people you don't know that
were born somewhere else who fucking got
jacked.
You get trapped in that
whole idea of you know,
this is my team,
these are my people and you know,
someone fucking plays a country music
song and throws up a flag and I'm in fuck
it.
It feels good.
It feels good to be in right,
feels good.
But God bless America feels good singing
around with a bunch of other people and
you're all drinking fucking baddest
motherfuckers on the planet.
Woo.
And that's how people get recruited.
It's a cluster fuck man.
These poor fucking kids,
man.
Do you imagine being 1819 being talked
into doing this shit for a bunch of
bloodthirsty motherfuckers who just are
trying to get whatever they're trying to
get over there.
Whatever the fuck it is,
whether it's a lithium,
you know,
minerals in the mountains that
they used to make cell phone,
whether it's 90% plus
the world's opium supply,
90 fucking percent.
That is a multibeam
multibillion dollar business.
And if you think these
fucking industrialists cock
suckers that are running the
world are going to leave that money
behind your fucking crazy dude.
They've got United States army
troops guarding poppy field.
There's fucking so much heroin there.
I mean,
it's incredible.
The fucking brother of the
president of Afghanistan,
his brother was selling heroin
and getting paid by the CIA.
I mean,
God dammit.
Heroin is absolutely addictive,
okay?
People who try heroin get
hooked on heroin is everywhere.
Okay,
so you need to sell it.
Someone selling who's selling it,
I don't know,
but 90% of it comes from this one place
where we have to be to save our freedom.
You can't criticize it
because if you criticize it,
you're a shithead.
You don't appreciate the troops
and what they're doing for you,
and that's not the case at all.
I just don't like the idea of these
fucking people leading us in any direction
where you need to sacrifice your life.
I don't believe it.
I don't believe them when there's
been so many fucking lies.
I mean the more you look it up,
the more they may go go into any of
the stories on the weapons of mass
destruction before we invaded and compare
them to what we actually know that
they really knew when they said that.
It's like they did it on purpose.
They wanted to get in there for whatever
fucking reason and if it's some crazy,
the world is going to end.
If we don't stop this,
but we can't tell you shit like
I would love to believe you.
I would love to believe that
the reason why you're a,
you're not telling us exactly what the
fuck is going on is because you're really
protecting us from some insanely
evil thing that if we knew about it,
it would,
society would collapse,
but our strong,
brave,
powerful leaders or gun to
guide us without our knowledge.
I would love to believe you if
you weren't all full of shit.
We're going to have to step back and
look at it all in a different way.
Dealing with all this nonsense that
we have with the two party system.
We're spinning our wheels.
We're not getting any traction.
This is all nonsense to
same nonsense with Obama.
If we dealt with with Bush
special interest groups,
controlling what people say and do and
what direction the country goes in and
save us from the bad guys,
shut the fuck up,
man.
It's the same nonsense.
Operation.
Northwoods was something that was plotted
out during the 1960s signed by the
Joint Chiefs of staff where they were
going to fake terrorist attacks that
American civilians and blame it on the
Cuban so we could go to war with Cuba and
involved a bunch of Shit
like blowing up a jetliner.
They were going to have a drone jetliner
blow it up and say that people died on
it.
And this was going to get everybody
fired up about going to war with Cuba.
They were even going to
tack won ton him obey.
They were going to arm Cuban friendlies
to attack Guantanamo Bay so that we
would have to go to war with Cuba.
I feel like the,
our own government,
they plotted out.
This is like real shit.
I remember when I,
I saw,
um,
JFK,
the Oliver Stone movie and that was like,
part of the premise that JFK,
that Oliver Stone was,
um,
was pushing in this film is that they
kill JFK because they want to stay in
Vietnam because they were making
a lot of money into Vietnam.
And I remember at the time
seen that movie going,
that is absolutely ridiculous.
Who the fuck believes that I going to
start wars and keep wars going just so
that they can make money even though
it's not a real war on a just war.
Nobody wants to go to a ward.
That stupid hippie bullshit.
Well,
as I got older and I started
investigating history,
you know from way back to Vietnam to
the Gulf of Tonkin to all the shit that
happened when the Kennedy and Nixon were
an office to all the shit that happened
with Reagan and the contras in Nicaragua
and that sends an Easter and all the
difference,
various things that have happened in
human history where it's clear that the
United States is,
you know,
we're fucking around with all kinds of
things all the time to make money and
that there's a bunch of people
that are profiting off of war.
And then there were doctors profiting
like a little bit of money here and there.
You'll,
you know,
you look at like what's going
on with like how much money,
how a and made for the war.
We're talking about billions
and billions of dollars.
That's like real money.
Eisenhower leaving office and he's giving
a speech warning the American people
about the power of the
military industrial complex.
You know when you watch that you like,
well,
here is a sitting president who's leaving
office and what was the most important
thing that he wants to tell people is
that you have to be careful because there
is a machine here that wants to go to war.
There's a business behind going to other
countries and fucking people up and
taking their shit,
and they come up with reasons to do this
and they sacrifice American lives to do
this and they do it for profit.
And it sounds absolutely ridiculous.
It sounds absolutely outrageous that
the greatest country on earth could be
involved in something
like that from the get go,
but yet that's what history says.
That's how it points the
points in that direction.
It points to that direction
that it's going in
and the councils of government,
we must guard against the
acquisition of unwarranted influence,
whether sought an orange zone by
the military industrial complex.
The potential for the disastrous rise
of misplaced power exists and will
persist.
We must never let the weight
of this combination in danger,
our liberties or democratic processes.
Yeah.
Okay.
Tower seven disturbs me the most.
That tower seven just went just
like a controlled demolition
and everybody's like,
yeah,
but it had holes in the building and
you see the hole in the building.
Yes,
I see the hole in the building,
but wouldn't it fall towards that whole,
why is it falling like that?
That doesn't make sense to me.
With tower seven
the way tower seven foul,
it just kinked in the middle and
fell down three false bead almost.
I mean everybody liked they'll,
they'll nitpick at you.
Oh,
it was one 10th of a second
slower than free fall.
Even if it was just close to free fall.
That's crazy.
There was no resistance.
It just gave up why we did life wiggle
and collapse towards where Jack got
jacked.
It does.
It just seems like a controlled
demolition that that bothers me.